it's so broad that it turns every single
student and every single faculty member
on campus at least arguably into
harasser hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV
with the president of the foundation for
individual rights in education Greg
lukyanov last week there was some news
in your part of the world which you call
the shocking affront to the United
States Constitution what happened after
years of universities relying on
harassment codes as that speech code
since the 1980s ever lied on harassment
goes to speech codes we thought we were
making real progress through a series of
court decisions and through it a through
fires good work to get the definition of
harassment into a sane understandable
narrow definition so people don't get
punished for teaching a class that has
racy content or for as you know as I
talk about in the book publicly reading
a book or for that matter implying that
it might be something negative to say
about a hockey coach which are all real
cases so we really felt like you're
making progress and it's all entirely
down the drain thanks to a letter that
was sent to the University of Montana by
the Department of Education and the
Department of Justice whereas there's a
very narrow definition of harassment
they've redefined harassment to mean
simply any unwelcome speech of a sexual
nature and also they eliminated the
objectively offensive prong of it so
basically any unwelcome speech of a
sexual nature even if it's unreasonable
for you to have objected to it so if I
say hey Greg you're looking kind of hot
today yeah is that seriously under the
definition of harassment absolutely and
that's part of the problem is it so
broad that it turns every single student
and every single faculty member on
campus at least arguably into harasser
what does it matter that the federal
government sent these letters and what's
the enforcement mechanism what does it
pertain to well the interesting thing
about the University of Montana case was
it was actually about assault but it
shows the way the discrimination law is
just sort of them crept up assault is
considered to be a form of harassment
the Department of Education has power
over federal funding and it is tasked to
prevent harassment on campus so in the
course of dealing with assault they
decided to well they were at it to
redefine harassment as essentially
really anything's I true related
whatsoever so to get this
straight here any federal education
funding yep is now going to go only to
those campuses that embrace this
definition of assault yeah absolutely
and there's only about four colleges
that we know of that don't accept any
federal funding whatsoever because you
have to remember this includes stafford
loans that lives includes any funding
whatsoever so what's the upshot of this
what's the possibility of fighting it in
any way well the only good news is here
is that I think that the government
might have overplayed its hand here I
think this is finally I hope this is
finally the last straw that's going to
cause universities themselves to start
pushing back against this ridiculous
over-regulation well this is all very
chilling and disturbing thank you very
much Greg and keep up the good fight
with it for recent TV I am Matt Welch